[Applaudissements]
j' avais l'a5 aussi ouais ouais pas qu'à
eric arthur erika mettez vous bien
autour de la table a donc erika à votre
avis je sens dans les yeux d'un goal
qu'on va passer mais je suis heureuse
parce que ça nous aurait tous mais aussi
j'aurais bien aimé le faire on good si
vous voulez le gone pas quartier à camon
berry coup et paca crime voulais dire à
grévin
[Applaudissements]
iphone et les habitants longeaient les
attentions
et
serviette
et les coeurs
essuyez points 8,6 des gens tombent
comme ça sur eux sur l'émission sens
avant de comparer messi potable on
regarde la caméra là bas un petit coup
de barre nouvelle résidence